does money buy happiness
i'm serious does money buy happiness pat
you seem like a pretty uh jolly guy
you know you know this you know i'm this
is a conversation we're actually just
having with erica let me a couple days
ago of him
and um it makes things a lot easier but
no
there's you can't you can't buy genuine
happiness there's no such thing about it
as as buying
happiness people make you happy
relationships make you happy uh
good health makes you happy you know
that's what makes you happy you could be
a millionaire a billionaire and you can
10 grand make me really happier
yeah there was a study out a couple
years you're gonna make the ask you
should have made the ass for 25.
there was a study out a couple years ago
that um they said that the number
where happiness sort of levels off yeah
is 70 000. thousand dollars okay all
right is it 75
so we're 11 level can you pull up the
article okay so look let's just
let you know don't pull it up yet
seventy five thousand dollars goes a
long way further in alabama
versus the new york city yeah but i
think like we talked about
money just exposes who you really are
right so i don't think
that's it listen you you were broke in
denver you're sleeping on friend's couch
versus yeah
you're having a million dollars in a
bank and you don't really care much
about money you're not really stressing
out about money no
when were you happier look i again i
i think i'm just as happy as when i was
broke i think i just have more options
now
okay okay so can money does money buy
happiness no
does it put a small little smile on your
face yes
if so if you don't have you're going to
have problems regardless no matter
money money doesn't eliminate problems
you're going to have money's a tool
and it gives you more options if you're
going to have problems anyway you might
as well be rich
i agree i agree yes so i asked this
question on twitter
and i got so many different responses
one of the guys said it best he says
money doesn't buy happiness but i've
never seen an unhappy person on a jet
ski
that's daniel daniel excellent and and
then another guy put up and he says uh
money uh the the money doesn't buy
happiness but the happiest place on
earth will not let you in without money
do you do you have an honest answer
because you've been broke now you're
worth it why did you ask somebody who's
got some money around here
there's money uh by happiness
probably has more savings here than most
people no i can't say most people
but kai's actually got more savings at
22 than almost all of us had i'm over
the entire office i'm over leveraged in
in crypto and i can tell you i was much
happier six months ago yeah okay there
you go
this guy's all in on dogecoin does money
buy headlines what do you think kai i
mean you know what don't go based on a
research well i can't agree to ask you
because we've talked about this
we spent a couple hours on this topic
david money buys happiness yes or no
uh my aunt won 500 in the lottery
yesterday and she was the happiest woman
in the house she showed me the video she
was crying
i'm gonna go with 500
you're going to go home and she's going
to be like yo why you narc bro irs
didn't even know about that
so so pull up the article by uh uh is it
visual capitalist or virtual capitalist
visual care visual great place great
place great these guys get six million
visitors a month they do a great job
just go to visual capitalist
and they have the numbers uh right there
click on that watch this here
click on the article kai go up okay so
watch this right there yeah
so if you're making 15 000 a year you
are
34 less happier than a person that so
look at the number at about 80 000
it used to be 75 now it's 80 right at 85
33 happier you see how the number goes
and if you go to 625 income 38 percent
happen
yeah i would agree with the happiest
i would agree with that they can't stop
smiling
so there is a part of it
and by the way the way these guys did it
is well-being
evaluating on well-being right a
person's mood how they feel throughout
the day
because if you go back and go go back to
the person that's in colorado
if i go back to the person that just got
out of the army i'm a dead 49 thousand
dollars
i'm on my way back from vegas after
maxing on my credit card
and playing blackjack and i'm in the
49th place
that drive back was a miserable run back
from vegas i'm not sitting there saying
oh my gosh
what a great weekend guys we crushed it
man
it's not on my mind so there is an
element to it but i will tell you
another guy from harvard they did this
study
can you pull up the other study do you
think poor people sit there and they're
like
am i happy i think that's a very rich
thing to be there like just sitting on a
pile of money like scrooge mcduck and be
like but is am i
really happy but do you know why this is
such an important topic
the reason why this is such an important
topic who tells you
those who have money isn't happy and why
do they tell you that they don't want to
share it
so think think about the statement the
statement about you know honesty
i'm a billionaire but when you are it's
really not that good bro like don't even
sweat it like stay at the 42 000 all
your income so i'll tell you yeah to
your point all right my my father wanted
me to be a lawyer more than anything in
the world and said you would have made a
decent you would have made a million
oh my god nobody would want to go
against it i give up what i did was
i i like i went and i talked with
ten lawyers they're my my my buddies
fathers and stuff like that and i was
like
hey look you know do you like your job
what's going on and every one of them
all ten of them said don't be a lawyer
this is the worst job ever you're going
to hate it i went back and i told my dad
i was like you know because the plan was
for me to go to law school in the off
season with baseball right
and he he comes back and he looks at me
he's like yeah did you look around the
parking lot did you see a lot of
mercedes
see a lot of bmws yeah they might not
like their job but the job freaking
works nobody likes their job
if you're gonna have to have a job that
you don't like you might as well make a
lot of money
nobody likes their job god said yeah
he's like i'm gonna give you i'm gonna
give you a tip here
people like hobbies if you make your
hobby into your job you're not gonna
like your job
nobody likes responsibility they don't
like waking up early they don't like
doing what somebody else tells them to
do
it doesn't matter what it is there's a
porn star out there there's a freaking
stud
dude he's just saying he's like porn
star there's a porn star out there
there's a porn star out there that has
to show up on set
and then you know have sex with
beautiful women and he's like
another thursday god and he hates his
job you know what i'm saying
once it's a job you're going to hate it
so make as much freaking money as
possible so you don't have to wait
were you like saying like your
aspirations in life is that kind of what
you mean oh yeah yeah
no but here's the thing pat i was going
into major leagues i don't need a job i
was gonna be a millionaire bro
i don't think that everyone hates their
job i think there's levels of
i enjoy my job but yeah i'd rather be on
a freaking jet ski
you know or like you know i really yeah
but the weight is that my
job his dad said responsibility nothing
about the word responsibility is sexy
you know the idea of last night
okay three times
three times last night listen let's like
do it somebody tell that damn
okay but so but at the same time
yesterday we're out there looking at a
project that we're working on right now
and i got this kid in my arm she's
crying the moment i pick it up she falls
asleep
and this morning i go by her and i'm
looking at her and i'm talking to her
and i'm you know just having you know
just doing my thing with the baby and
i'm kissing her on the stomach she's
asleep and she goes like this
body do it melted my knees buckled i'm
like i almost fell on the floor
responsibility comes with a lot of like
pressure and
and you know things that you have it
drives you though what an incredible
yeah
what it comes with it you're dead
honestly i i want to have your dad on
the podcast that's it it's game over we
want the real
gerard on the podcast
oh you think he's throwing my government
out there so let me give you the other
side let me give you the other side so
harvard does a study it's a 75-year
study i don't know if you guys have
heard about the study already
telling us about yesterday yeah we were
talking about last night so harvard does
a study
and they followed a group of it's like
100 people they followed
for 75 years yeah so the people that
started the study and died
they had certain protocols that next
generation continues it that works for
harvard wow and every year they check
with these people that they're talking
to and asking questions
so listen you're 45 now what what about
what do you value the most right now
versus what it was at 44.
hey you're 46 now hey you're 55 now hey
you're 65 now
and they're following this right and kai
if you can pull up this article i know
there's a ted for it but see if you can
pull up the article
do you know they said at the end of the
day what made them
the most happiest in life has to be
family it has to be
it was it wasn't family really no it
wasn't family it was
all relationships yep 100 of his
relationships meaning
meaning relationships no no but because
let's face it some people have family
you're okay being away from you know
some people don't have the family you
want to be around all the time because
they're miserable
and one of the things he said these
people that they research and ask the
questions of
yeah it's an 80 year old study it's a
fascinating study one of the things they
talked about is the fact that
it's also important to be with people
that are
growing yep so if you stay with
relationships that are no longer growing
that doesn't serve you bring your
happiness
so if you're friends with the friend
that you were in high school and the guy
has
no aspirations you're trying to go to it
up in life this this guy's not going to
bring you happiness because it's going
to
make you feel like had a friend of
mine called me one time
one of the most annoying phone calls of
my life so this guy sends me a tape kai
you remember this when i showed you the
videos you showed me the video with
soccer all this stuff with this kid is
killing this guy i love this guy he's
like a brother tilted i love this guy
sends me this video and he's trying to
get some money for this uh
equipment for his kid right and he's
going to show me this stuff this is a
guy i knew from 16 years old we go back
when i was 16 15 years old and he says
hey i got this can we get on the call i
get on to come like listen man the video
was the sickest video i freaking love it
and i love the fact that you're spending
time with your kid
and how can i help he says i want you to
buy this machine i said are you doing a
gofundme i said i want you to buy it
it's 2 000
i said why are you why don't you i'll
contribute but
why do you want me to buy for 2000 where
do you have the money well why don't you
guys go to public and do gofundme i'll
be the biggest contributor
no we don't want to do that with our
friends and family but we just wanted to
come to you because we think you would
help us out with this
i said first of all i'll help you out
but what why the pressure on me having
to pay a hundred percent of it because
you have the money you can afford it
i'm like i know i can afford it but that
does mean does that mean i have to go do
this for everybody
no so why don't you do go find me i'm
telling you i'll support it well no it
says and here's the other thing i think
you the reason why you want to do this i
said what's that and this was it i was
like this i'm like i'm going to do it
and surprise the kid
and i'm not even going to tell him about
it i'm going to send this machine to his
house and i'm going to surprise him
right
until he made his last comment you know
what the last comment was
here's the last comment he says i was at
rafi's place the other day
and i ran into a couple of the old
friends that we had from 20 years ago
and they weren't saying good things
about you i said really what were they
saying he said they were saying that
ever since patrick became successful on
all this stuff he doesn't come to la
anymore and all he cares about is
success of money
i said and she says if you get this for
me i'm going to help
recreate and improve your relationship
oh hell
no do you realize what that did to me
well all right
i'm sorry what did you just say what did
you just say
he says yeah this one i said did you
really just say that to me
i said if you know me for 26 years
and i've always been the only guy that's
had your back why don't you just do me
anyway this
and you allow people like that to talk
to me
to you privately and now you want to
tell me you're going to help with my
reputation
he says look sometimes i say stuff i
shouldn't say i said i said i'm sorry
man that was probably the worst thing
you can say to somebody not only that
there is no friendship why did they feel
comfortable enough around you to talk
about me
exactly what jay-z says don't tell me
what people said behind my back tell me
why
they're so comfortable to say it to you
right what's the point
here's the idea that energy that energy
of a comment like that
pulls you down oh my god happiness is to
get away with those relationship because
you have no idea to control
a comment like that has on a human being
oh yeah how it can
retract you from your dreams i would
think about that non-stop all day long
it would just ruin my
like my whole dad pat's friend if you're
listening to this you're a freaking
idiot
yeah you know you know i came back and i
come see me bro
come see me i'm in cali my boy i'll see
you let me let me let me put it to you
this way let me put it through this way
this guy here
when we were coming up and i'm thinking
about like even when we were doing other
things in life
no matter what he ever did i had his
back comments like this
unbelievable so but but think about it
for your own self like it's not even
this is not even
with a friend i'm not even gonna if
you're listening friend comment but pay
so we read it on air yeah by the way but
here's the point though for some of you
guys that are listening this has nothing
to do with my friend
go to that one friend or family member
that every time you're around them
they say yeah but okay
so you're around this person and you're
like hey let me tell you what just
happened dad hey let me tell you what
just happened here bro hey let me tell
you because here's what we just did
yeah but does it really even matter i
bet the guy that you're even working
with he's the guy that probably doesn't
care about you
yeah but does it ring yeah but this yeah
but adam yeah but
constantly they will drag you down so
eventually
you know you're you're making money
you're succeeding mario and i are at the
house we're having this conversation
together when we were moving to florida
i had a very simple statement one night
to mario
i announced the announcement that we're
moving to florida and i said we're going
he says pat how can we do this man what
if people don't come i said mario
i'm 41 years old 42 years old right now
here's the conclusion i have with my
life
the only people i want to be around when
i'm running and i want to make sure all
their dreams become a reality
is true believers true believers let's
go you're not i don't guess amari if
it's just me and you moving to florida
this is still going to be one of the
biggest media companies in the world
because we're going to fight till the
very end we have a message
we have an audience people resonate with
us we're going to do our part let's go
hey here's what we're doing you and your
ad it's cool
but this is what we're doing this is our
move so you know
relationships the value of good
relationships if you
value good relationships long term so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye